the jurogan experience remember when
dennis miller would say a bunch of crazy
[ __ ] that like
no one could know people would laugh it
would be like the most obscure
references about like the
1400s had to know what he was saying or
you were a [ __ ] loser yeah talk about
arafat babe you're like that sounds
pretty good i was on a plane with nor
mcdonald once just randomly and he sat
next to me goes you know
he doesn't even know any of that
he's stuff yeah he's just [ __ ] uh
finds out and writes it down and he just
says it it's not like he knows it norm
on the on the dennis miller show is
unreal yeah yeah he's on great clips
miller my hero yeah yeah the most norm
thing ever to not tell everybody that
you were dying
what a g
damn a total norm move too right yeah
sympathy from everybody
he got cancelled he could have put that
card on the table cancer
[ __ ] yeah and he didn't even
tell his best friends he said he was
going to canada to take care of his mom
tell me either he told out amiga he's
got a big race coming for him he didn't
tell adam
adam
that's the last joke
genius comic though genius he was so uh
unique in his the way he expressed
himself how he was really thinking like
the way he would like he would say
something [ __ ] up to you in the green
room he would say the exact same thing
on stage it was just and he would say he
had this way of looking at things it was
absolutely unique to him yeah he bombed
a good bit too yeah
which must have been so fun to watch
caroline's once [ __ ] throwing down
one
my god it was like he still cares two
didn't care he got heckled he was
drinking a coca-cola and he got heckled
and he was like
i don't want to do this
i was gonna go back to my act and that
was it yeah completely random just like
you don't feel like it right now yeah i
could don't want to completely randomly
two times in my life i sat next to him
on a plane just totally right
vancouver at the airport yep once in
vancouver and one somewhere else and the
last one he was talking about yeah quit
smoking he's telling me how he quit
smoke yeah it was hard it was really
hard to quit and i did it and you know
[ __ ] smoke it's terrible for you so
we land he
walks as fast as he can off the plane
right into one of those stores and buys
a pack of cigarettes and he's opening up
it and he's got one in his mouth as he
stepped out the door he went off for an
hour about how it's terrible for you
he's so glad he's out over it so i'm
outside with him i go what are you doing
i thought you quit smoking about all
that i'm talking about and i wanted a
cigarette so was he being funny or was
he just a weirdo no no no he was just a
genius he didn't drive right he did not
drive just invited people to go do
tennis and stuff so he'd like pick me up
on the way his brain was just wired
different yeah it was just wired
different all the time but like he just
decided wow let's smoke and just
i mean he couldn't light it quick enough
on the way out the door watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify